[Music]
once a long time ago there was a
powerful hermit named look Tom oniy a
say he had three promising students mone
McCullough the brilliant goddess of the
Seas for a joined in princely
manifestation of the earth and rien a so
a demon whose heart burned with
passionate fire locked ah wished to
bestow a gift upon his most deserving
student to determine which of the three
that was he announced a contest whoever
first brought back a glass full of
morning do would be master of this
mysterious gift when dusk came vorich
own andrea meso ventured into the forest
they left not one leaf or blade of grass
untouched impatiently shaking the
precious fluid into their glasses when
they return to the hermits hut they
found mone makalah sitting patiently
with a full glass of morning dew she had
left her shawl out overnight and won the
contest
by simply wringing out the fabric over
her glass proud of all his students and
loving them like his own children
Luke toss surprised all three with gifts
he turned the dude riah meso collected
into a diamond axe for a Chun's into a
magic dagger and mony makalah's into a
crystal ball unlike anything ever seen
soon rhea meso grew covetous and decided
he must have michael AHA's prize he and
for Achon tried to woo the goddess so
they could get the precious gem but
after she rejected their advances and
flew off
Rema so resolved to take the crystal
ball by force
rhea meso flew through the air in search
of mony makalah propelled on by a
jealous rage on his way he encountered
flora Chung and attacked him knowing
that the righteous prince would never
allow him to steal the crystal the demon
gained the upper hand in the heat of
battle and hung against the side of a
mountain
sure Roberto John's death rien a so
continued his search until he finally
found mone makalah he demanded that she
and her friends either submitting him
the most brilliant of luck toss students
and rightful master of the crystal ball
or die like Buddha John
makalah without fear refused and flew
off into the clouds hoping to draw the
demon away from her friends EMA so took
the bait ripping through Nimbus after
Nimbus in his crazed pursuit
once far enough away makalah confronted
her pursuer ria meso made one last amend
but the goddess remained unfazed enraged
he began to swing his diamond axe before
he could roll the weapon
makalah threw her crystal into the air
as it climbed the height of the sky it
emitted powerful flashes of lightning
and blinded the demon Rianna so let his
axe loose in a wild desperation as the
weapon flew through the air it cut
through clouds creating deep rolling
peals of thunder and when the lightning
and thunder mixed precious seeds of
water fell from heaven rain mekka la
drew close to EMA so now blind and
impotent without his axe she pondered
what she should do to the murderer
remembering the kindness and love of her
teacher Moni makalah shows compassion
and flew into the sky shortly later
r.e.m aiso regained his strength found
his axe and father
and thunder lightning and rain continued
to dance across the earth some drops
fell on Votto Chung and revived him his
in golden like a rice field ready for
harvest grabbing his magic dagger he
flew into the sky in search of rien a so
and mony McCullough if you enjoyed this
video check out our ever expanding
library of ancient myths in this
playlist and if you like what you see
subscribe to our channel for new
animations every week
[Music]